loin of pork rich sumptuous is the most
tender part of the pig this is better
when it's slightly pink yes that's right
granny pink first of all you have to
score that fat on the outside you get
some really nice crispy crackling score
if you haven't got a sharp knife I mean
really sharp you just standing like that
works brilliantly stuff just slice into
the center and open it up and look
lemon zest it gives it a really nice
summery zesty lightness sage sage and
pork go brilliantly well together
parsley garlic nice little thin shards
salt pepper olive oil like a blanket of
aroma fold it over just like an envelope
tie
I put the string in the pot to stop it
running around
salt pepper olive oil mop it up it
smells amazing is not even kilcher
straight in hot oven 45 minutes just
matter of that is amazing look crispy
cracking rest untie carve nice thick
slices
that's what I like to hear that noise
crispy correctly
tender and delicious
fragrant lemon zest with a sage and a
parsley extraordinary pork loin with
lemon and sage done the crispy topping
you can see what that deserves to be a
great British classic vanilla cheesecake
with berry compote done